意外とイケてるな
意外とイケてる
こんにちは
(嗚咽)
こんにちは、はじめしゃちょーです
お久しぶりです、文房具コーナー！
シャーペン触る機会はだいぶ減ったんですけども
シャーペンの情報はちゃんと毎回いれております
けどね、シャーペン業界もちょっとだけ息詰まってるのかしんないんですけど
デルガード、オレンズ、クルトガかな、もうここらへん
この3つが出てからちょっとね、なかなか新しい商品が出なくなりまして
もうね、あれぇ、ほらアプリゲームとかよくあるじゃないっすか
強いキャラが出すぎてその強いキャラより強いキャラが出なくなっちゃうんですよね
その今出てるオレンズ、デルガード、クルトガあたりが
強すぎるんでなかなかそれを越す新しいシャーペンが出ない
すごいシャーペンであれば僕も紹介したいんですよ
紹介したいんですけどもなかなかこう新しいシャーペンが最近は出てないので
悲しいです！！
というわけで学生が終わってもシャーペンは全然好きなので
今回はすごい、これはもうやばいよっていうのをきました
わざわざ東京に筆箱持ってきたっていうね
結構、スタメンのシャーペンが増えて来たんですけども
昔めちゃくちゃ褒めたコチラのシャーペン覚えてますでしょうか
こちら”SMASH”でございます
製図用シャーペンに近い細さを持つ、このシャーペン
グリップもつぶつぶで
なんといっても書き心地がすごい気持ちいというシャーペン、SMASHでございます
やべ、俺の本名が書いてある
特徴としては
ここの先っちょですね
普通のシャーペンなら
多分、黒いここで止まってシャー芯が出るんですけども
銀色の筒が伸びて、ここから出てるので
製図用シャーペンは基本的にこの作りなんですけども
自分がどこで字を書いているのかが分かりやすいというか
ピンポイントで字が書けます
たまんないっすわ～
今回なんと
なんとですねぇ
SMASHのオリジナルカラーが発売されました
あの.
すごいですよ！！
これはかなりすごいことです
SMASHのオリジナルカラー5色発売されたんですけども
販売されている場所がもう、ロフトだけという
ロフト限定のSMASHのオリジナルカラー5色出たというわけなんで
僕ですね、東京に行く前に
静岡の駅前にあるロフトに売ってるSMASHのシャーペン全部買ってきました
うわあ
こちらでございます
今回はね本当に
このSMASHの新色カラーが出たという事の素晴らしさと
SMASHの素晴らしさを再確認する動画でございます
5色！展開されております
( ^)o(^ )
1色ﾀﾘﾅｲ
ｳｵｵｵｵｵｵｵｵｵｵｵｵｵｵｵ
ｵｲｵｲｵｲｵｲ ｱｯｱｯｱｯｱｯ
売り切れてました
うああああああ！
こちらの4色は確保しました
白、緑、ピンク、青でございます
で、もう1色どっちかと言うと、そっちが一番欲しかったんですけども
赤黒
赤が売ってたんですけども
どうやら人気すぎて静岡のロフトには売ってませんでした
(´;ω;｀)
一番欲しかった・・・
いやでも、オイラもちょっと動きが遅かった
もうちょっと、情報仕入れてすぐ買いに行けば買えたんでしょうけど
中々、ロフトに行く時間がなくて行けなくて
ひとまず、この4色はゲットしたんですけども
細かく見ていきましょう
色です
はい、順番に見ていきましょう
まずはコチラ
緑です
もうね、この、なんかね
SMASHと言ったら、このカラーのイメージしか無いから
まさかのオリジナルカラーが出るとは僕も思ってませんでした
いや～たまんないよ、このフォルム
うひえ～(´^ิ益^ิ｀ )
これで字書ける時代に生まれた君たちはホントに幸せ者だよ
続いて白
白もねなんかね
いろちょうがね（色調かな？）
あーでも俺はあんまり好きじゃないな
すいません、正直に言いますけど白はあんまり好きじゃないです
でも、なんかよくいるじゃないですか
筆箱を白黒で統一してる
なんか、牛系女子みたいな
牛系女子の人は多分こういうのが似合うのかと思います
ひとまず、書きやすさは僕が保証するので
ピンクもねかっこいいね
ちょっとビビット系のね濃いピンクなんですけども
出来る女って感じですね
僕、赤を抜いたら多分青が一番好きなんですよね
¿どうでしょうか
もうね～すごいよ
勉強したくなっちゃうもん
これで勉強できるんですよ
僕が手に入ったのはコチラの5色でございます
安定した書き心地
製図用ならではの正確に書ける感覚
あと、サイズなんですけども
Dr,グリップと比べると結構ね割と細め
なので、僕みたいに手が大きい人だとちょっとね小さく感じることがあるので
そこは注意しましょう
僕は小さく感じました
こんなので字書けるんすよ
ふ～☁ ☝ˆ~ˆ☂
( ^)o(^ )ｽﾞﾁｬﾁｬﾁｬﾝﾁｬﾁｬﾝ
待って、今SMASHで字書こうとしてたんだけど
ね～SMASH中にそれはちょっと
も”しも”し～～？
後輩：もしもし～～～！！
後輩：先輩静岡っすかー？
はじめ：え？今東京だよ
後輩：え、ウソー
後輩：今日帰るんですかー？
はじめ：いやー多分今日帰れないんだよなー
後輩：え、いいんすかそんなんで
はじめ：え？帰ってきてほしい？
後輩：帰ってきてぇぇ
書いてみるよ一回
*書きこみ中*
これが解の公式です
で、xのあたいが何かか分かるという、そういう式になっております
そういう話ではない
一番何を見てほしいかと言うと
やっぱり、ここですね
製図用シャーペンならではの
銀の部分が長いので
どこに字を書いているか
グラフをどういう風に書いているかが、はっきりわかるというのもポイントでございます
はいというわけで
SMASHを使って色んなYouTuberの似顔絵を描いてみました
やっぱ製図用だから細かく描けるんですよね
はいというわけでいかがだったでしょうか
SMASH
昔、SMASHの動画出した時
SMASH使ってみてすごい良かったよって人が多かったので
一回使ってみてほしいです
なので、なるべくシャーペン選びはね
自分が書きやすいやつを選んでほしいんですけども
その一つとして、やっぱりこのSMASH
大変オススメでございます
いやぁ～やっぱ俺、赤黒が欲しかったあああ
東京のロフトとか売ってないかな
行ってみようかな
ちなみにぺんてるさんのホームページのネット販売全て売り切れでございます
うえええ
皆さんのロフトに売ってたらよかったら是非買ってみてください
まじでオススメです
これさえあれば
もう、大学受験、高校受験、もうウェイってできます
ウソです
( ^)o(^ )
～＾ED＾～
ででででん
じゃあな！
嬉しいな～